指を通すことで
スマホやタブレットPCを指一本で楽に持てる
スタンドにもでき、
落下防止にもなる
便利なリング
バンカーリング
後ろがシ－ルになってって、今貼ってあるんですけど
剥がすと
ここが粘着部分になって
背面とかにこう貼ると
ここに指を通すだけで
スマホが指一本で持てると言う
便利アイテムです
まさにこんな感じだね
こういうつき方をします
ipadとかにも普通につけれます
は
うおぉぉ
こういう感じ
もこうなるとでも
ipadも指一本操作ができて
スタンド代わりも
なります
やべえ
アヒージョ
（スペイン語：ajillo）
そんなバンカーリングなんですけども
僕は、そう
バンカーリングに
無限の可能性を感じております
出て来い！
お前ら！
はい
と言う訳でこちらに
バンカーリング20個準備しました
こちらのバンカーリング20個でなにしようかと言いますと
そう
粘着力
もう 机も多分持ち上がりますよ
無理だった
ipadとか楽々持ち上がるんで
かなり強いです
この粘着力を使って
バンカーリング20個を天井に貼り付けて
僕は家の中にブランコを作りたい
穴がね一直線状になるわけですよ
こういう感じで
想像してください
こういう感じで一直線状にして
ここに縄を通します
で、その縄に板をつけると
ここに俺が乗ったらさぁもう
強いわけじゃん粘着力が
最強よ
最強
こんなにスマートフォンのアクセサリーでブランコができるなんて誰も思いつかない
僕、天才よ
今回は自信あります
一個ですごい粘着力ですよ
で、というわけで今日は
バンカーリングで
おうちに
滑り台
じゃないほう
…
wwwww
マジミスったw
ブランコを作ろうと思います
では行こう！
自信しかねえ
今日は自信しかねえぞぉ
はい、というわけで
作って行きま  しょう
必要なものはこちら
バンカーリング20個
ロープ
ブランコ用の板
天井 ↑
これだけで簡単にブランコができます
僕が今日証明してあげるよ
見てろよみんな
という
わけで
まずは
バンカー
リングを
天井
に
つけて
行きます
よ
ではやって
行きま
しょう
場所取り大事、よし
どうでしょうか
こういう感じにつけていきます
うほお～
いいね～
いい感じ  いい感じ
おｋ
(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ
ｵｵ(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ
ｵｵｵｵ(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ
ｵｵｵｵｵｵ(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵｵｵｵｵ
ｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵｵｵ
ｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ(ﾉ´▽ˋ)ﾉｵｵ
ｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵΣ(ﾟ□ﾟﾉ)ﾉ
あああぁ
ｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵL(´▽ˋL)
ｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵｵ\(´▽ˋ\)
おっしゃあ
おｋです
おｋです！
バンカーリングの装置完成しました
次はこのバンカーリングのリングに
紐を通します
あーっはぁ
こんなに要らないよぉ
あ  切ればいいのか
あぁ…やらかしたわ
もうダメだ
俺これやばいだ  多分
直せねぇ
は
は?
は???
は?????
お
おぉ
おぉ！
o----- ﾟД ﾟ-----o
とりあえず通してみます
一回通そう
ﾀﾀﾀﾀﾀﾀ\(ˋД´)/
\(ˋД´)/ﾀﾀﾀﾀﾀﾀ
ﾀﾀﾀ\(ˋД´)/ﾀﾀﾀ
赤ちゃんは
産道を通り
狭い門をくぐり抜け
尿道から
生まれてきます。
※腟からです。
あぁ
いいんじゃない
いいよ  いいよ
ブランコの椅子になり部分
うわぁ 危ねぇ 滑る
これをこの椅子にくくりつけて
ブランコの完成です
そもそもここで浮くかどうかが勝負ですから
よしー
おｋじゃないんすか
まぁここはね多分余裕だよ
ブランコの重さでね多分落ちることはないと思う
はい完成ですw
おぉｋおｋおｋおｋ
おぉ  ヤバい
本物じゃん
待って
うおぉ  ブランコだ
www
wwwww
wwwwwwwwwww
マジもんだよこれ
すごい
待って俺
マジブランコをつくちゃった
特に問題なく、動いております！
ブランコ自体は完成しました
あとは強度の問題だ
本物の遊具ってものは
どんなに重い人が乗っても壊れない
注意が書きがなければな
乗れる気しかねぇんだよなー
20個でしょう
ipad 20個分でしょう
いや絶対行けるよ
やぁちょっと緊張してきちゃった
一回切ります
はい、というわけで実際にライドオンしてみましょう
これは行けるでしょう
行きます
wwwwwww